la parole est maintenant à mon collègue
mme anna marie mercier pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
mercredi 27 jeudi 28 et vendredi 29
avril
le gel a frappé le vignoble de bourgogne
mais aussi les vignes de nombreuses
autres régions de france ces épisodes de
gelée ont été particulièrement
importants et leurs impacts sont
dramatiques voire irréversibles
il s'agit de pertes de récoltes sèche
estimé entre 50 et 60% par exemple à
mercure et rully ou bouderont en saône
et loire où 300 hectares de vignes sont
impactés en côte-d'or puligny montrachet
et chassagne meursault corton beaune
mais aussi dans l'yonne
de lourds dégâts sont aussi à déplorer
certains domaines ont perdu jusqu'à 100%
de leurs récoltes
mais les pertes sont très variables
d'une parcelle à l'autre
ces gelées printanières sont extrêmement
rare et grave surtout lorsqu'elles ont
lieu trois jours de suite les assurances
récoltes restant cher beaucoup de six
vignerons ne sont pas assurés aussi
monsieur le ministre je souhaite votre
intervention pour classer en
catastrophes naturelles ces trois
épisodes de jeu les suspendus reporter
le paiement des charges sociales à la
msa différer les subventions agrimer
pour permettre aux exploitations de se
remettre sur pieds financièrement avant
d'engager d'autres investissements
ajourner les remboursements d'emprunts
des viticulteurs impacté auprès des
organismes bancaires
monsieur le ministre pourriez vous me
confirmer que le gouvernement prend
toute la mesure de la catastrophe
naturelle qui s'est abattue sur notre
vignoble et qu'il compte intervenir pour
soutenir nos vignerons
la parole est aux ministres de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire
monsieur stéphane le foll pour deux
minutes ce président madame la sénatrice
j'ai lu dans les visages à l'évocation
des vignobles que vous avez cités nombre
de connaisseurs et d'amoureux des vins
de bourgogne
sachez que le ministre en fait partie
vous avez évoqué un gel ce qui arrive
tardif et qui a des conséquences sur la
future école de 2016 et vous vous êtes
posé la question de savoir si le
gouvernement était mobilisé bien sûr
nous sommes mobilisés sur ce sujet qui
va porter donc sur le magazine 2016 et
qu'il faudra qu'on évalue au moment où
ses récoltes aurait pu aurait dû avoir
lieu
les conséquences en termes de pertes
économiques avec vous l'avez évoqué des
possibilités d'allègement de reports de
charges qui seront de toute façon mis à
la disposition de l'ensemble des
vignobles et puis aussi sur les achats
et sur les questions de stocks liés à
ces vignobles
je rajouterais un point vous savez sur
ces débats on a eu à plusieurs reprises
des accidents climatiques très important
là il s'agissait de gel mais nous avons
connu des graines et des sécheresses
mais des grêles surtout qui ont causé de
graves dégâts
aujourd'hui et ç'avait été un débat avec
gère césar qu'on a poussé et qui avance
sur l'assurance qui est nécessaire de
mettre en oeuvre pour arriver à faire
face à ces aléas climatiques
donc je vous le rappelle on a beaucoup
progressé il faut encore qu'on progresse
et des propositions supplémentaires sont
à faire sur ce sujet mais soyez certaine
madame la sénatrice que sur cette
question comme sur d'autres d'ailleurs
le gouvernement est aux côtés des
viticulteurs et mettre en oeuvre toutes
les dispositions nécessaires pour leur
permettre de redresser une situation
effectivement difficile on a remercié
pour 15 secondes
merci monsieur le ministre plus que
jamais nos vignerons et nos domaines
viticoles ont besoin de votre soutien
cette filière ne veut pas être plainte
elle veut aider le gouvernement
porterait une lourde responsabilité de
ne pas l'accompagner
merci